[Musique]
depuis le 16 juin les députés de la
commission d' enquête consacrée à
l'épidémie de covin 19 auditionnent les
acteurs de la crise sanitaire le monde
médical mais aussi les ex ministres et
directeurs généraux de la santé tout
l'été lcp vous fait revivre ces
auditions aujourd'hui la parole est aux
soignants cinq organisations syndicales
sont interrogés par les parlementaires
mesdames messieurs chers collègues nous
reprenons les travaux de cette mission
dont je répète que je présiderai je
pense sur cette semaine là afin de
pouvoir continuer nos travaux nous
prenons ces travaux de cette mission
autour la thématique de la prise en
charge hospitalière des malades du cog
hill et plus largement de la réponse du
système de santé à la crise sanitaire
mes chers collègues nous allons
auditionner cet après midi madame astrid
petit membre de la direction fédérale de
la fédération cgt de la santé et de
l'action sociale
monsieur gilles gadier secrétaire
fédéral de la branche santé de la
fédération force ouvrière
monsieur olivier oui nous co secrétaire
du syndicat sud santé de l'ap-hp madame
clotilde cornières secrétaire national
la fédération cfdt santé social sur de
santé sociaux et monsieur maxime serein
conseiller technique à la fédération de
l'union nationale des syndicats
autonomes unsa santé et sociaux publics
et privés mesdames messieurs je vous
remercie tout d'abord de votre présence
parmi nous aujourd'hui le système
hospitalier en général et plus
particulièrement dans les régions les
plus touchées a été soumis à rude
épreuve et a réagi grâce à l'implication
sans faille des personnels soignants et
les personnels administratifs auxquels
nous rendons une nouvelle fois hommage
l'accueil et le traitement des malades a
nécessité le déploiement de moyens
nouveaux de réorganisation selon le plan
blanc ceci a retenti sur l'organisation
du travail en termes de congé de temps
de travail consécutives d'heures
supplémentaires de renforts vers
d'autres services ou d'autres
établissements
nous avons souhaité aborder ces
questions directement avec les
personnels et leurs représentants
comment s'est passée la mise en place du
plan blanc
a beaucoup parlé des manques en
équipements de protection individuelle
qu'en est il
comment ont été organisés les renforts
de personnel en un mot comment pouvons
nous être mieux préparée dans le cas
d'une épidémie sachant que si
l'expérience est importante chaque
épidémie comporte sa part d'inconnu
avant de commencer cette audition
mesdames messieurs je vais vous demander
de prêter serment
en effet l'article 6 de l'ordonance du
17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires impose aux personnes
auditionnées par une commission denquête
de prêter serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité rien que la vérité
je vous invite donc chacune et chacun a
levé la main droite et à dire je le jure
merci beaucoup je vous rappelle donc que
cette audition et public elle est
diffusée en direct puis concile
consultable en vidéo elle fera l'objet
d'un compte rendu écrit qui sera publié
je vous donne donc mesdames messieurs la
parole pour un propos liminaire de
quelques minutes sachant que vous êtes 5
donc je vous invite à ce que le propos
soit le plus concis et rapide possible
pour que nous puissions enchaîné par les
questions de mes collègues c'est à vous
merci merci donc à strip petit pour la
fédération cgt santé action sociale
nous vous remercions nous avoir
sollicité à cette commission d' enquête
sur la crise sanitaire liée à l'épidémie
qu'ovide et d'entendre le témoignage que
les organisations syndicales peuvent
vous apporter sur 7 sur cet épisode
la cgt est la première organisation
syndicale des personnels de la santé et
de l'action sociale
pendant la crise nous avons mené deux
enquêtes de grande ampleur auprès de nos
syndicats pour mesurer l'évolution de la
situation et objective est ce que les
nombreux témoignages des personnels nous
indiquait sur la situation terrible en
cours les analyses sont à votre
disposition nous les avions transmis en
amont de cette réunion elles sont aussi
en libre accès sur le site cgt santé ces
enquêtes apporte beaucoup d'éléments
chiffrés
c'est une démonstration édifiante sur ce
qui n'a pas fonctionné et pourquoi nous
avons ainsi pu mettre en lumière
dès la fin du mois d'avril la
surcontamination des personnels
soignants à un moment où cette question
était ignoré depuis le gouvernement a
fait un décompte est en effet il ya bien
une surcontamination avérée des
personnels soignants ce que nous pouvons
établir aujourd'hui c'est si c'est qu'il
n'y a pas eu de fatalité à ce que trente
mille personnes meurent en france de
l'épidémie ou à ce que tant de collègues
soient contaminés par le virus
c'est le résultat de défaillance de
décision politique délibérée ou de lois
adoptées ces dernières années contre
notre système de santé et contre la
sécurité sociale le bilan humain est
lourd il aurait pu en être tout
autrement si nous avions eu les lits
d'hospitalisation qui ont été fermées
par dizaines de milliers et ce par tous
les gouvernements successifs réduction
qui continuent d'ailleurs encore
aujourd'hui si nous avions eu les
masques le matériel de protection et des
médicaments dont nous avions besoin
les tests auraient pu éviter des
milliers de contamination dans les ehpad
mais nous ne les avons pas eu nous avons
aussi découvert que des recommandations
ministérielles conseillé de maintenir
les personnes âgées malades à leur
domicile ou dans les ehpad plutôt que de
les accueillir à l'hôpital nous ne
pouvons que nous interroger car tout le
monde sait que la moitié des décès déco
vide en france proviennent des ehpad et
pourtant nous avions alerté bien en
amont de cette épidémie sur le manque de
personnel sur les dangers de fermer
temps de service hospitaliers de
structures sociales les personnels
avaient dénoncé leurs conditions de
travail et notamment la situation dans
les ehpad ce qui apparaît c'est que
contre toute attente c'est que l'hôpital
n'a malheureusement pas pu faire face à
la crise sanitaire il n'en n'avait plus
les moyens
année après année les budgets dévolus
aux dépenses d'assurance maladie votée
au parlement sont toujours contraints
est toujours en dessous des besoins de
la population
nous le savons tous et les lois
concernant la santé n'ont eu de cesse de
diminuer l'offre de soins publique
or il est incontestable que c'est le
secteur sanitaire public qui a fait face
à l'épidémie
par ailleurs nous avons pu voir pendant
la crise une accélération des atteintes
aux droits des salariés dans notre champ
les plans blancs les plans bleus horaire
des rogatons rêve de travail dérogatoire
affectation imposées au personnel repos
supprimer ou imposer voir une
augmentation significative des
situations de dépassement d'actes
professionnels
nous assistons dans plusieurs endroits
aujourd'hui à une forme d'opportunisme
pour pérenniser ces dérogations mise en
oeuvre dans des circonstances
exceptionnelles et plusieurs
propositions du ministère dans le ségur
vous aussi dans ce sens
contractualisation de quota d'heures
supplémentaires demandés aux personnels
des gens sous-effectif de se remplacer
les uns les autres ou encore la mise en
place de rémunérations variables
notamment en lien avec un entretien
d'évaluation professionnelle
ce ne sont pas exactement les process
les promesses gouvernementales entendu
pendant la crise les personnels avaient
cru comprendre que leur salaire serait
augmentée pas que leurs droits seraient
attaqués il y aurait eu la crise est
désormais l'après crise il nous semble
difficile de considérer que la crise est
terminée tant la situation dans nos
établissements et critique actuellement
on peut même dire que la crise sanitaire
perdure encore maintenant en france les
centaines de milliers de patients dont
les opérations chirurgicales le suivi ou
les consultations ont été annulés et
reportés affluent désormais dans les
services et les lits manquent toujours
les personnels sont épuisés mais reste
toujours en sous-effectif la dangerosité
et la pénibilité de nos métiers n'est
aujourd'hui plus à démontrer nous avons
payé un lourd tribut par l'exposition au
virus sans le matériel de protection
suffisant
et pourtant il semblerait que la
reconnaissance comme maladie
professionnelle ne serait réservé aux
collègues ayant eu des formes graves de
la maladie
ceci est vécue comme une profonde
injustice tout comme l'a été la décision
de verser au personnel une prime
exceptionnelle différentes selon les
départements où leur établissement en
conclusion un chiffre la fédération cgt
a mené en juin une nouvelle enquête sur
la situation dans notre secteur à
presles déconfinement à la question des
salariés de votre établissement at il
démissionné ou ont-ils l'intention de
changer de profession à la suite de la
crise sanitaire 37 % de nos syndicats
nous répondait avoir connaissance de
telles situations
nous ne le supposions pas la tante
d'amélioration des conditions de travail
et salariales des salariés dans notre
champ est donc énorme
merci pour ce cours propos liminaire je
vous laisse prendre la suite monsieur
donc fédération fo santé
gilles gadier je vous tiens à vous
remercier de nous avoir invité à cette
table ronde afin de porter la parole des
agents dans le cadre de cette commission
d enquête sur l'impact la gestion et les
conséquences de l'épidémie de covile 19
notre fédération représente l'ensemble
des personnels secteur hospitalier
médico social et social
voilà même si on m'a informé par
téléphone que nous étions plutôt sur les
aides-soignants ou les infirmiers
m'a-t-on dit au téléphone
je tiens à souligner ici que cette crise
sanitaire à impacter l'ensemble des
personnels travaillant à l'hôpital
quel que soit leur grade ou leurs
fonctions donc il ne s'agit pas pour
nous aujourd'hui de pointer du doigt les
responsabilités de rechercher le
coupable parce que ce n'est ni notre
rôle et notre volonté mais l'intérêt
véritable de cette audition pour nous
qui sont venus ici c'est de procéder à
l'analyse de la situation où vous aider
à procéder à l'analyse de la situation
par les informations qu'on pourra vous
donner durant par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé durant la crise sanitaire
mais c'est également dans l'objectif de
bénéficier de retours d'expériences afin
d'apporter les corrections nécessaires
et d'éviter la reproduction de certains
faits donc pour entrer dans le vif du
sujet notre fédération rappelle qu'elle
dénonce depuis des années à la fois les
modes et les insuffisances de
financement des établissements de santé
à la fois de santé médico sociaux
le glissement vers un mode de gestion
faisant de plus en plus apparaître une
gestion hôpital entreprise comme on a
l'habitude de le dire
et ainsi la gestion des stocks s'est
dégradée pour finir par fondre comme
neige au soleil et nous amener à la
situation que nous avons connue avec une
carence des moyennes protection
individuels et collectifs manque de
masques / blues / chaussures lunettes et
cetera
mais également manque de matériel
la réanimation de produits médicamenteux
ou de fermetures de lits qui ont été
trop nombreuses et que nous dénoncions
depuis un certain temps donc pour autant
la panacée tristani terre la gestion des
moyens et des organisations du travail
se sont articulées au plan local autour
des chsct
j'aborde cette question parce que c
était la pierre angulaire de
l'organisation dans les établissements
et la loi du 6 août 2019 de
transformation de la fonction publique
prévoit la suppression des chsct et la
naissance des commissions spécialisées
dans un comité social d'établissement
avec des prérogatives qui seront
différentes et notamment plus grave
encore un seuil qui serait différent
passant de 50 agents à 300 ce qui veut
dire qu'on entérinerait le fait qu'il
n'y aurait plus de sel chez s'était
quasiment dans l'ensemble de des ehpad
en france et ça nous paraît
particulièrement gravissimes quand on
sait que les personnels représentent les
représentants du personnel au chsct ont
des formations spécifiques en termes de
prévention par rapport à l'hygiène
insécurité et bien évidemment aux
conditions de travail donc tant que je
suis sur le chsct
nous avons relevé une anomalie quand
même qui nous apparaît de taille puisque
c'est un autre demande unique et
uniquement à notre demande que s'est
réuni le chsct national
nous avons demandé le 6 mars une réunion
extraordinaire du chsct national pour
faire un état des lieux sur la situation
sur les moyens de protection les flux
les stocks etc
les incidents c'est à dire que combien
de personnels étaient contaminés comme
il pouvait y avoir de décès nous avons
eu le premier singe a cité un mois après
c'est à dire le 8 avril et il nous
apparaît comme une anomalie que ce soit
une organisation syndicale qui soient
dans l'obligation de demander un chsct
national alors que nous étions en pleine
crise sanitaire et que nous avions tous
beaucoup d'interrogations à apporter et
des réponses à apporter évidemment au
personnel que nous représentons donc à
ce titre bien évidemment dans le cadre
du pilier de simplification du ségur
nous avons demandé le maintien du chsct
pour la fonction publique hospitalière
ça nous paraît être quelque chose
d'incontournable
voilà
moi je vais pas être plus long par
rapport à l'introduction je pense qu'on
est avant tout ici pour répondre à vos
questions à vos interrogations
voilà je vous remercie excusez moi juste
un exemple jusqu'à un dernier exemple le
ministère de la santé avait publié sur
son site le 13 mars qu'il fallait porter
des masques ffp2 dans tous les hôpitaux
et qu'ils étaient apportées tout le
temps donc juste un exemple le chu de
strasbourg le 14 mars le syndicat il
faut du chu de strasbourg de strasbourg
adresse e mail à la direction pour
demander l'application du protocole
édité par le ministère de la santé
opposition de la direction pour mettre
en application le protocole parce qu'ils
suivent la vie du club comité de lutte
contre les infections nosocomiales
donc le 25 mars
enfin les directives du ministère de la
santé sont appliquées mais entre temps
bien évidemment alors entre temps où
pendant 30 ans je ne peux pas le
démontrer mais il ya eu 600
professionnels au chu qu'on était quand
même contaminé voilà et dernier exemple
au chg de sarreguemines
nous avons une collègue qui était
représentant syndical qui étaient
manipulateurs d'électroradiologie donc
il a été en contact avec des personnes
infectées
il n'avait pas de moyens de protection
il y à un chsct qui s'est tenue au
centre hospitalier pendant le chsct
il a dit qu' il avait été bien contact
qui n'avait pas eu de moyens de
protection que c'était inadmissible
quelques jours après il a été
diagnostiqué porteur du virus
il a été hospitalisé pendant trois mois
en réanimation et au moment où je vous
parle il est décédé et jeu
lorsque je dis puisque j'ai dit je le
jure donc il y as compris il y compris
des enregistrements qui atteste que je
suis en train de dire merci olivier
youinou pour la fédération sud santé
sociaux je suis co secrétaire du
syndicat sud santé pour l'assistance
publique-hôpitaux de paris je suis par
ailleurs infirmiers anesthésistes dans
cette grande institution difficile de
prendre la parole après ce témoignage
mais on en aurait tous de ceux de
témoignage de cet ordre-là de
contamination de nos collègues et de
décès de nos collègues dans l'ensemble
de nos hôpitaux
mais avant d'aller plus à fond le jeu
voulait d'abord vous remercier de nous
recevoir de pouvoir nous entendre sur
une crise qui nous a touché
particulièrement fortement et qui n'est
pas sans laisser des traces
aujourd'hui encore dans nos
établissements dans nos équipes et plus
largement dans nos têtes
pour ma part j'ai abandonné mes
délégations syndicales dans ce contexte
là pour rejoindre les équipes venir en
renfort dans l'établissement et prendre
part parce que mon métier le
permettaient parce que mon métier était
essentielle à ce moment là dans les
équipes de l'assistance publique et tout
particulièrement à l'hôpital henri
mondor de créteil mais avant tout les
soignants comme les autres deux membres
de la population ont traversé cette
crise de la même façon et je voulais
dans un premier temps faire comprendre
vous mettre à l'esprit l'idée que le
confinement ne peut pas être une réponse
à un problème de santé publique que
c'est certes un choix politique mais ça
que ça ne peut pas être une décision le
sécuritaire et le liberticide ne peux
pas te ne peut pas être ne peuvent pour
le peuvent pas être des réponses un
problème même pandémique comme celui que
l'on a traversé l'homme est un animal
social comme disait l'autre et de se
confiner d'être restés ou de rester chez
soi n'est pas propice à l'état de
bien-être qui est la définition même de
la santé donc
l'idée dans ce contexte n'est pas tant
de savoir si les uns et les autres ont
fait du mieux qu'il pouvait avec ce que
l'on avait comme moyens mais de savoir
si l'on pouvait faire mieux que ce que
l'on a fait est à l'évidence oui la
crise du coc vide 19 a mis en lumière si
ce n'est la faillite au moins la
défaillance du système de santé public
français et de l'hôpital public en
particulier parce que ce qui a été
présenté notamment je prendrais cet
exemple là comme des exploits de
transformer en chambre réanimatoires un
tgv sncf pour transférer les patients
n'est que le reflet d'un échec du
système parce que on n'a pas su trouver
dans les bassins de vie des solutions
pour l'hospitalisation de ces patients
là c'est pas ça tombe pas comme ça des
nues c'est l'effet de politiques
austérité emmené depuis trop longtemps à
coups de restriction budgétaire et de
fermetures de lits massive sur
l'ensemble du territoire qui ont amené
dans les régions les plus touchées
je pense au grand test au goût au nord
et à l'île de france
cette situation qui ne nous a pas permis
de spitz alizés l'ensemble des patients
qui le nécessitaient défaillance donc à
minima peut-être faillite du système et
au delà ce qui nous a frappés aussi
c'est la situation de dépendance de la
cinquième puissance mondiale économique
du monde
sur un sujet aussi crucial au coeur même
je pense du pacte républicain
s'agissant d'un bien-être commun et de
l'accès de la santé à tous quelle que
soit sa situation financière sociale
quel que soit l'endroit où l'on vit
je crois que c'est le message fort qu'il
faut retenir de cette crise là et
surtout que ce que l'on a traversé on ne
leur traverse plus je crois qu'on le
disait pendant la crise qu'on n'oubliera
pas qu'on n'oubliera rien mais on ne
veut surtout pas reconnaître ça je me
suis demandé si j'allais écrire un texte
comme mes autres camarades mais j'ai
préféré vous livre est comme ca brut
les résultats d'un brainstorming que
l'on en a mené dans nos équipes de soins
et qui est assez révélateur juste par un
listing de mots comme ça de ce que les
uns et les autres ont pu traverser de
positif parce qu'il y en a eu du positif
et de négatif parce qu'il y en a eu
aussi en positif
la mobilité est l'adaptation de
l'hôpital et de ses personnels les dons
qui ont afflué les dons qui sont venus
compléter ou pallier à un manque
institutionnels des dons en matériel des
masques qui nous sont venus
d'entreprises qui était à l'arrêt et qui
ne les utiliser plus ça a été quelque
chose qui a été important la
communication si je crois que on a des
directeurs ont peut-être est-ce
particulier à l'assistance publique mais
en tout cas ça mérite d'être relevé qui
ont communiqué autour des
et de la situation au jour le jour j'ai
des comptes rendus de réunions que l'on
avait en visioconférence avec eux et qui
nous faisait le point régulièrement de
la situation de
du nombre de patients hospitalisés en
médecine en réanimation mais aussi du
nombre de
l'agent de leurs salariés contaminés
aussi au jour le jour
et ça ça a été plutôt quelque chose de
bien vécue par les soignantes quand on a
pu leur communiquer comme on l'a fait
ses propres résultats
le rapprochement des équipes aussi qui a
été importante et l'attachement qui
était déjà avéré un mets qui s'est
concrétisée dans le cadre de cette crise
l'attachement au service comme une unité
fonctionnelle de l'hôpital et non pas
dans ces grands vaisseaux où ils veulent
tout ce nous amener des supras groupe
hospitalier ou des départements médicaux
universitaires on est perdu là dedans
c'est plus qui dirige sa la crise a
remis les choses au clair et a confirmé
ce que déjà des enquêtes sociales avait
dit l'attachement des hospitaliers
qu'ils soient médecins ou non médicaux à
la notion de service et à la notion
d'établissement
la reconnaissance de la de l'aco vide
comme une maladie professionnelle ça a
été plutôt vécu positivement aussi il ya
également du négatif vous imaginez bien
et les mots sont très forts là aussi
quand on parle d'insécurité de sentiment
d'abandon d'aucune préparation fin de
formation
le manque de moyens pas simplement de
moyens de protection mais les moyens
médicamenteux des moyens de matériels
médicaux
le stress de l' angoisse parce que ce
qui a été vécu comme positif cette
mobilité possible des agents n'a pas été
de tout confort quand on s'est retrouvés
infirmiers ou aides soignants de
services hospitaliers transférés dans le
contexte vert de la réanimation c'est
pas les mêmes passions que l'on prend en
charge c'est pas les mêmes soins que
l'on fait et c'est des facteurs de
stress et d'angoissé important pour les
personnels pas d'intégration pas
d'encadrement des protocoles à géométrie
variable on l'a vu un
alors même que la communication
gouvernementale était elle aussi
géographie et la géométrie variable
c'était pareil sur les recommandations
et notamment de nos équipes
opérationnelles d'hygiène qui adapte et
les bonnes pratiques en fonction des
stocks que l'on avait ça a été tout
particulièrement vrai sur les masques ça
a été seconde errements sur les
surblouse aussi remise en cause des
pratiques des bonnes pratiques
professionnelles de devoir faire des
choix dans nos patients par manque de
lignes de qui bénéficierait d'un lit de
réanimation ou pas c'est quelque chose
qui a été particulièrement dure à vivre
la relation que l'on avait nous mêmes
avec une eau propre famille quand on
était
sur le front possiblement touché par le
cos vie de tous les jours et qu'on
rentrait à la maison j'ai des
témoignages de collègues qui ce qui
prenait 3,4 douche d'affilée qui se
changeait dans les garages avant de
revenir dans le foyer
c'est des choses qui sont pas faciles à
vivre non plus c'est pas facile non plus
pour les familles de le vivre beaucoup
d'exemples comme celui ci qui nous font
dire en fait que on n'adhère pas du tout
champ lexical qui avait été choisi par
le gouvernement de faire de nous des
héros vous voulez guerrier on est
simplement des professionnels de santé
on aimerait être reconnus comme tels
parce que de parler de héros ou de
guerriers permet de parler aussi de
dévouement d'engagement plutôt que de
parler de conditions de travail je pense
qu'il est grand temps d'en parler de
conditions de travail tout comme il est
grand temps de parler de la
reconnaissance de ces métiers qui sont
d'utilité communes qui sont d'utilité
sociale qui ont montré combien il était
au coeur de du pacte républicain dans ce
contexte précis les conditions de
travail
c'est pour les hospitaliers et non et or
or crise des comptes épargne temps parce
que on a été dans la capacité de leur
donner des 35 heures hebdomadaires les
comptes épargne temps et pour la seule
assistance publique c'est un million
cent mille jours épargnés sur des
comptes
ce sont de véritables heures
supplémentaires qui n'ont été ni
travaillent et qui n'ont été ni
récupérer ni rémunérées elle est là la
véritable date de l'hôpital aujourd'hui
elle est une dette sociale elle est une
dette vis-à-vis de ses salariés
si la crise permet de pallier à tout ça
au moins il y aura quelque chose de
véritablement positif
merci à vous
madame cornières pour la fédération cfdt
santé-sociaux une fédération qui à la
fois publiques et privées
nous vous remercions de nous rencontrer
de nous recevoir dans le cas de cette
commission denquête en tant que
représentant des plaintes des personnels
la pac et la gestion de cette crise a
été importante
ce que nous avons pu voir nous écouter
constater c'est que le ministère le
premier ministre n'avait pas d n'avait
pas les capteurs de 6 passes et sur eux
sur le terrain
une grande partie des ars ont été
incapables de remonter les informations
des situations de ce qui se passait
localement avec parfois des informations
contradictoires
nous avions des équipes qui interpellait
les ailes les rs et qu'ils n'avaient
aucune réponse particulièrement sur les
autorisations spéciales d'absence sur le
confinement sur les heures
supplémentaires
des informations contradictoires entre
les ars et les directions des
établissements
il a fallu que la djs mais des foires
aux questions pour réguler les
informations et voire même parfois avec
des interprétations différentes
les ars se sont focalisés sur les
hôpitaux sans prendre en compte le
social et le médico social sans tenir
compte de cette spécificité concernant
particulièrement les équipements
professionnels individuels
on ne peut que constater qu'il n'y avait
pas de vision des stocks
il y avait également un déficit
d'équipement criant pour les services
techniques de la discrimination intra et
extra hospitaliers
par exemple dans la branche et l'aide à
domicile où les personnels n'avaient pas
de masse et un manque de reconnaissance
et de méconnaissance de leur profession
dans le médico social
les équipes pointent est seul avec pour
tout recours le confinement
le confinement qui était le révélateur
de la compétence des directions un
déficit également de stocks de
médicaments et de matériel pour
lesquelles parfois les hospitaliers
ainsi que les entreprises ont dû faire
preuve d'ingéniosité pour répondre aux
besoins
on pense entre autres au respirateur il
n'y a pas eu de réunion de la part des
ars avec tous les acteurs au moment du
confinement pas d'implication des cons
et départementaux pour le médico social
et social alors que c'est du champ de
leurs compétences dans les
établissements si ça a marché c'est que
le système ne s'est pas grippée c'est
grâce au professionnalisme des des
salariés là où il ya eu du dialogue
social l'évier et où les directions ont
laissé de l'autonomie aux équipes ça
bien fonctionné les équipes ont su
s'organiser
on a souligné le lien important nous
avons souligné nous le lien apportant
qu'a eue avec la tjo s qui quand elle a
tenu compte des remontées du terrain a
su apporter des réponses et fluidifier
les relations entre les organisations
syndicales syndicats les agents et les
directions
parce que cruellement seul sur le
terrain le dialogue social a manqué
cette crise sanitaire a démontré la
capacité d'engagement des personnels
elle a démontré que là où il y avait de
la formation du dialogue social cela là
où il n'y avait pas d'informations
dialogue social cela a généré stress
peur bien sûr la situation étant
différente selon l'ampleur de la
pandémie et les régions la crise
sanitaire a mis en avant l'importance de
l'hôpital public et de sa capacité à
s'adapter rapidement à la situation de
crise s'il fallait le démontrer c'est
fait alors que celui ci était mis à mal
depuis de nombreuses années subissant
coupes budgétaires après coupes
budgétaires ces professionnels dans dans
dans la rue depuis plus plusieurs mois
n'était pas non plus entendu l as mis en
avant l'importance de la filière soins
avec le premier niveau que sont les
échanges le personnel responsable de
l'hygiène hospitalière
je prends pour exemple dans la région
grand-est hôpital de coop de colmar
avait fait le choix
détesté analyser cette compétence le
personnel privé a refusé de venir
travailler
le personnel s'est retrouvé en
difficulté cette crise a également mis
en avant de la société qu'il existait
des métiers et des services essentiels
majoritairement exercées par des femmes
mais reléguée au plus bas de l'échelle
des rémunérations des qualifications il
est temps aujourd'hui que ses
compétences induites ceux reconnus comme
indicateur de richesse
concernant le personnel il y à une
déréglementation importante du temps de
travail tanks dans le sanitaire avec la
mise en place dès 12h
et un confinement temps dans les ehpad
ce confinement à poser plusieurs
problèmes sur le temps de travail la
rémunération et l'hygiène comment des
personnels petit accepté de dormir à
même le sol et les conséquences sur les
collectifs de travail puisque tout le
monde n'était pas volontaire
la question de l'engagement a généré
également des choses under du
professionnel du professionnalisme parce
qu'être professionnel c'est aussi savoir
prendre du temps et du repos quelles
conséquences cela entraînera sur les
collectifs de travail et les incidences
sur la vie personnelle
on voit aussi arriver et les
professionnels le verbalise ils disent
ne plus vouloir exercer avec un
sentiment contradictoire à la fois des
de fierté et de plus jamais ça il eut
une perte de goût de confiance des
professionnels dans le système elles
peur que les politiques ne tire pas les
leçons de cette crise les professionnels
aujourd'hui et nous le verbalisent ne
font plus confiance à leurs dirigeants
et en la gouvernance les annonces
pendant la crise ne se sont pas
traduites par les faits on peut prendre
exemple sur la prime qu'ovide est la
reconnaissance d'un mât de la maladie
professionnelle je vous remercie
maxime saury pour l'unsa santé sociaux
donc petite précision avant d'être
conseiller technique je suis infirmier
de réanimation et représentant syndical
monsieur le vice président la fédération
unsa santé sociaux vous remercier pour
cette invitation permettant un échange
sur la situation de la gestion de la
crise qu vite 19 dans les établissements
relevant de la fph au préalable je tiens
à rappeler les circonstances dans
lesquelles ce secteur se trouvait avant
l'arrivée de cette épidémie
cette crise sanitaire est arrivé dans un
contexte où le personnel soignant
techniques et administratifs soit
l'hôpital ou dans le secteur médico
social était déjà en grande difficulté
par beaucoup de perte de repères et le
peu de considération que nous ressentons
induit par plusieurs éléments notamment
la loi de transformation de la fonction
publique qui acte la suppression des
chsct qui durant cette crise a démontré
toute l'efficacité et l'utilité de cette
instance mais également la politique
managériale porté par l'efficience là où
dans un milieu professionnel qui
traquent humain c'est l'efficacité qui
doit être mis en avant le manque de
moyens humains et matériels que nous
livrons quotidien
cette crise a révélé le un hôpital en
souffrance mais également mis en exergue
les carences d'un système de santé tout
entier il est indéniable que cette crise
sans précédent dans l'histoire
sanitaires que nous avons il sommes
toujours en train de traverser a
cristallisé les failles et les
insuffisances de notre système de soins
cette crise a mis en évidence les
difficultés liées aux politiques
d'austérité nationale qui se sont
succédé depuis plus d'une dizaine
d'années dans notre secteur dans le
sanitaire mais aussi dans le social et
médico-social qui ont et crée des
tensions importantes notamment sur les
moyens humains mais aussi les carences
sur les stocks et flux de matériel de
protection et sur certains produits
médicamenteux par exemple les curares
tout ceci nous interroge sur la place
dit j'ai acheté un rapport de l'igas et
est publié en janvier 2020 qui démontre
une situation très hétérogène sur le
territoire et la capacité de réaction
des directoires avec les ars ainsi que
de l'état stratège de notre pays elle a
également mis en avant cette faculté
d'adaptation de réactivité de mes
collègues à l'hôpital mais également des
établissements médico-sociaux et sociaux
en particulier les ehpad grâce aux
acteurs de terrain ainsi que le
dévouement et la célérité d'un collectif
de travail durant toute cette pandémie
à ce titre permettez moi de rendre
hommage à tous mes collègues qui ont
assuré la prise en charge de nos
concitoyens dans des conditions de
travail dégradées au prix de leur santé
vie privée et voir de l'heure
je voudrais même rajouté qu à l'heure où
nous échangeons des collègues avec qui
j'ai traversé la crise sanitaire
qu'ovide 19 sont partis ce matin même en
guyane pour aller d d'autres collègues à
l'eau bout du monde
l'audition de ce jour nous amène à
échanger sur le bilan de la crise
sanitaire
je tiens dans le cadre de mes propres
introductif a précisé qu'à ce stade
aucun bilan n'a été présentée aux
organismes aux organisations syndicales
de la fonction publique hospitalière sur
ce sujet si lors du dernier conseil
commun le 25 juin
le bilan de la crise qu vie de fonction
publique a été discuté en instance il
m'apparaît essentiel compte tenu du fait
que notre versant était en demeure était
et demeure en première ligne face à la
crise sanitaire
aucun bilan spécifique fonction publique
hospitalière soit effectuer d'autant que
souffert de ma part très peu
d'informations relevant de notre
versants ont été communiqués lors de ce
conseil commun ce bilan doit être
exhaustif comprenant des éléments
quantitatifs et qualitatifs qui ne vont
particulièrement quai durant la crise et
la gestion de celle de celle-ci
recensement des difficultés
dysfonctionnements mis en lumière des
manques de moyens que ce soit en
matériel de protection dispositifs
médicaux comme les respirateurs et
produits médicamenteux
le nombre de contaminations et de décès
au sein du personnel relevant de la
fonction publique hospitalière
cette idée m est d'autant plus
fondamentale que la reconnaissance en
maladie professionnelle des agents
atteint par la copie 19 et relevant de
notre versants et en est en cours de
finalisation juridique le nombre dasa
soit en raison de la vulnérabilité de
l'agent soit pour garde d'enfants même
si sur ce point des mesures ont été pris
avec le ministère l'éducation en ce sens
mais également sur le plan local la mise
en place du télétravail également
surcoûts financiers des établissements
liés à la gestion de la crise co lead et
un état des lieux du versement de la
prime qu'ovide avec les différents
répartition entre 500 1000 et 1500 un
tel bilan serait extrêmement précieux
est riche d'enseignement afin de pouvoir
mieux appréhender les prises de
décisions en cas de nouvelle vague
j'en resterai là en propre entre du ctif
et donc ne manquerez pas d'aborder les
points forts mais aussi les points
faibles de la gestion de la crise durant
nos échanges
d'un point de vue pratique aux pratiques
je remercie toutes et tous pour ses
propos introductifs monsieur le
rapporteur avant de passer à vos
questions sait où me autorisée je vais
poser quelques questions à mon tour 4 4
questions d'abord avoir votre votre
regard sur le fait qu'un certain nombre
de soignants ont trouvé que pendant
cette crise du coronavirus on avait pu
avoir
et vous l'avez souligné à certains
égards eu quelque chose une structure
une organisation plus agile peut-être
parfois allégé avec probablement un lien
avec la gouvernance simplifiée
c'est une un désengagement du ségur la
santé quelle est votre vision sur le
rôle de la gouvernance dans dans les
hôpitaux
un deuxième point vous soulignez tout à
l'heure monsieur gallier s'agissant des
masques une recommandation sur le site
du ministère de la santé sur les ff p2
est-ce que vous pouvez nous
éventuellement nous produire 7
cette recommandation pour l'information
de la commission et je voulais justement
vous interpellez là dessus puisque
puisqu'en fait selon vous en tout cas
cette recommandation proposée donc des
ffp2 aux soignants avaient aviez-vous
notion de du fait que les effets
spéciaux n'était pas réservé à tous les
soignants en fait puisque monsieur
valais et monsieur graal anciens
directeurs généraux de la santé nous ont
affirmé en audition que les fesses pde
était réservée aux soignants pratiquant
des actes invasifs uniquement donc voila
c'était pour avoir votre point de vue
là-dessus troisième point vous citiez
tout à l'heure une directive une
recommandation ministérielle
s'agissant de la prise en charge des
patients qui n'aurait pas été fait
patient émanant d pad et qu'il n'aurait
pas été hospitalisé c'était une
recommandation ministérielle c'était un
document dont vous avez eue
connaissances possession si vous pouviez
éventuellement nous et nous nous le
produire pour l'information de la
commission et à qui a été envoyé ce ce
document et enfin dernière question
c'est un livre que vous avez abordé le
nombre de patients deux patients pendant
de soignants contaminées selon santé
publique france on est aux alentours de
d'un chiffre important de 31000 et vous
l'avez souligne donc je crois que vous
êtes en accord avec vous aujourd'hui une
estimation un retour des déclarations et
surtout des reconnaissance en maladie
professionnelle maladies
professionnelles qui selon le ministre
de la santé avait été demandée en
reconnaissant systématique à partir du
moment où il était avéré qu'il y avait
une contamination quelle que soit
l'origine de la contamination
avez vous des retours là dessus merci
beaucoup l'est se répondre dans l'ordre
que vous le souhaitez mais en étant s'il
vous plaît relativement concis puisque
vous êtes assez nombreux à intervenir
merci beaucoup
oui alors concernant l'organisation qui
vous a apparu plus agiles de l'extérieur
en fait il y avait un report dans la
plupart des interventions qui pouvait
être reporté à l'hôpital donc on n'était
pas si je suis maman ça ne m'est pas
apparu jeu certains soignants ont estimé
qu'il s'agissait d'une organisation plus
agiles selon un article du monde
d'accord donc selon force ouvrière il
nous apparaît que si nous avions
quelques marges de manoeuvre d'armes
une autonomie sont toute particulière
puisque l'agilité pouvait provenir selon
nous du fait que
la plupart des interventions
chirurgicales n'était plus programmer la
plupart des consultations programmées
n'était plus programmée et que donc nous
étions je dirais concentrer sur la crise
sanitaire est concentrée sur la lutte
contre le convie 19 donc bien évidemment
ça laisse des marges de manoeuvre mais
ça voudrait dire que l'hôpital public
il faudrait qu'ils fonctionnent en
permanence comme ça et nous étions là
incité cette crise et il n'est pas
possible de fonctionner comme ça puisque
il faut répondre aux besoins de la
population et les interventions
chirurgicales et doivent se dérouler
même celles qui ont pu être reportés
parce qu'elles n'étaient pas d'une
urgence vitale immédiatement sur le fait
de démontrer la publication sur le site
du ministère je pense que le ministère
doit avoir un fake je vais essayer de
retrouver ça j'ai toutefois ma
possession bien évidemment les échanges
de mails entre le syndicat et fo du chu
de strasbourg et la direction du chu de
strasbourg
et oui bien évidemment j'étais au
courant que les ffp2 était plutôt
apporté lors dans le cas de la salle de
rêver ou lors de soins critiques
ceci étant dit le 25 mars il était
apportée par tous les agents qui
travaillent et aux urgences du chu de
strasbourg
voilà la situation avait évolué et nous
avons pu remarquer que d'un bon nombre
d'établissements
il n'y avait pas de recommandations de
port de masque parce que au départ de la
pandémie ce on va dire que les
informations que nous avions nous en ag
pas où nous disait pas que ça allait
nous protéger en particulier et puis
petit à petit au fur et à mesure du
déroulé on s'est rendu compte qu'en fin
de compte fallait porter les masques et
la preuve j'en ai porté un pour venir
jusqu'ici encore aujourd'hui donc je
pense que quand on est soignants quand
on est directement au contact des
malades
je pense qu'il faut se prémunir et je
pense également parce que je le sais
le code du travail prévoit que
l'employeur doit donner taux moyen de
protection à ses salariés qu'ils soient
fonctionnaires ou pas voilà concernant
les masques également j'ai à ma
connaissance un certain nombre des pâtes
qui se sont fait un petit peu dépouillés
de leurs stocks pour que ces stocks
partent en direction des établissements
de santé des hôpitaux et dans les ehpad
il y a des gens très fragile et donc ça
nous a apparu comme être non sens et
j'ai personnellement interpellé la
direction générale de l'organisation des
soins
lors de notre première chsct national
que nous avons fait un visio conférence
pour les alerter sur le sujet parce
qu'on comprenait pas bien pourquoi on
allait démunir il fallait protéger tout
le monde bien évidemment mais les sujets
des plus fragiles était dans les ehpad
d'après les scientifiques et les
professionnels merci beaucoup sur la
première question s'agissant de
l'organisation plus agile dans le
contexte et puisque l'on devrait en
tirer comme
conclusion est peut-être comme pistes de
réflexion à travers une nouvelle
organisation de l'hôpital et une
nouvelle gouvernance de celle ci à
l'évidence on a démontré à travers cette
crise là alors même que l'exécutif nous
faisait savoir que c'était coûte que
coûte et qui du coup il n'y avait pas de
contraintes budgétaires que les
difficultés sont venus d'ailleurs en
fait hein parce que on peut débloquer
les les tiroirs proposer des lignes
budgétaires si on n'a pas le matériel
pour et le matériel à acheter
on reste dans la même difficulté
sur l'hôpital c'est le cas typique de la
commande d'un milliard de masques en
chine qui ne sont jamais venus qui ont
été détournés de ce que j'ai cru
comprendre sur le tarmac de vue caire en
egypte parce que les américains allaient
me plus cher des stocks qui nous était
destiné sur paris sont partis à new york
donc à l'évidence on a montré quand même
des directions beaucoup plus à l'aise
dans la mesure où il y avait plus cette
contrainte budgétaire et des équipes de
soins qui du fait de cette facilité
était beaucoup plus à l'aise aussi dans
leur prise en charge dans l'eure
leur profession de tous les jours ne
s'attachant que là pour le coup ce qui
doit faire notre quotidien c'est de
progrès du soin en fonction des besoins
de la population donc ça c'est une
expérience qui est très intéressante
je sais pas si elle doit ou elle peut
avoir des répercussions sur la
gouvernance elle même mais à l'évidence
on a partagé beaucoup plus que l'on ne
faisait j'ai vécu moi qui ne suis plus
un perdreau de l'année vous le remarquez
un retour à un début de carrière ou ont
partagé beaucoup plus dans les équipes
dans les services où on se réunissait
quand les cas étaient difficiles on
prenait des décisions en collectivité en
équipe
le médecin écoutait ce que l'infirmier
qui venait de passer deux heures avec le
patient
avait à lui dire de la façon dont ils
sentaient le patient et on prenait des
décisions ou de maintien ou d'arrêt de
la thérapie dans ce contexte là on a
revêtu sa dans le cadre de la crise qu
vide et c'est plutôt un bien donc
tout ceci pour dire que les expertises
ne s'arrêteront pas un laitage médicaux
administratifs
si on doit reparler d'une nouvelle
gouvernance de l'hôpital il faudra je
pense à intégrer tous les personnels de
cet épisode là et je pense tout
particulièrement aux plus nombreux que
l'on représente ici
aujourd'hui
qui n'ont que des places
deux strapontins dans des instances où
on leur demande leur avis et où en
général on en a que faire de ce qu'il
l'est cet avis donc à l'évidence plus de
démocratie sanitaire passe aussi avec
beaucoup plus d coûte est beaucoup plus
de centres décisionnels partagé par
l'ensemble des personnels et très
certainement aussi par la population et
une meilleure représentation des usagers
eux mêmes parce que à l'évidence si on
écoutait et les personnels et les
usagers
on n'aurait pas fait de l'hôpital ce
qu'il est aujourd'hui et on aurait
maintenu sa présence sur l'ensemble du
territoire au plus près dans les bassins
de vie sur la vision de la gouvernance
je les dis un peu dans ma déclaration a
le constat qu'on a fait nous ce qu'on a
vu les remontées du terrain que nous
avons eue c'est quand ya pu avoir un
dialogue social assez fluide entre les
directions et les équipes s'amusent je
vais te dire un peu de manière familiale
de l'huile dans les rouages et à partir
de ce moment là les équipes pointé en
capacité de s'organiser et de faire des
propositions d'organisation de travail
aussi cette régulation du soin aux
autres et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
important parce que c'est quelque chose
que les équipes s affaire de tout temps
c'est aussi faire elles sont en capacité
de faire elles sont en capacité
d'organiser le travail et son capacités
quand il ya un gros problème pour moulin
neuf une crise est bien de mettre les
choses en place et devenir travail et ne
pas s'occuper et de se réguler comme au
collet de l'adie aussi il ya un
resserrement du collectif qui leur
permet de prendre les décisions et les
bonnes même en même en cas de
déréglementation et sa femme et ses
filles
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui est
important et c'est un constat que nous
avons fait ce qui a été un peu mal vécu
c'est vrai la réquisition des masques
dans les ehpad
c'est quelque chose qui a pas été très
bien compris par le peuple par le
personnel nous ils lui disaient mais
nous aussi on a des personnes à
s'occuper il ya des gens malades comme
on fait on est malade on doit venir
travailler quand même on nous dit que la
personne pour nous remplacer on est
susceptible en avait des professionnels
qui nous a plu en me disant mais moi je
suis enfin j'ai des symptômes et tout ça
mais c'est pas grave je dois venir au
boulot quand même j'ai pas de protection
comment je fais
comment je suis voilà donc ça c'était
une chose qui était mal vécu et dont je
pense sera doux nous pensions qui aura
un traumatisme
pendant un petit moment je continue un
peu sur les autres questions on y
revient peu après au lieu où si on
voulait faire circuler la parole du
radeau question de toute façon après je
n'en doute pas merci vous juste sur
effectivement on a eu des remontées nous
nous aussi de personnel en ehpad et même
compte cet ehpad appartenait à un centre
hospitalier dont faisait partie du
sanitaire avec les collègues qui nous
appelaient qui nous disait mieux on peut
pas envoyer les personnes âgées en réhab
on peut pas les envoyer un service de
médecine dans l'hôpital s'est refusé on
doit se débrouiller et moi je me
rappelle entre autres sur l'hôpital de
saint dizier un collègue me dire mais
ils sont en train de mourir on ne fait
rien
enfin on ne fait rien pour nous en tant
que soignant mot ne fait rien on sait
pas quoi faire on les regarde mourir on
les soulage c'est tout ce qu'on peut
faire et ça je crois que c'est pas
acceptable aujourd'hui et donc c'est des
choses sur lesquelles il va falloir
aussi que l'on réfléchisse et cordages
comment on a pu met déjà des usagers de
ces situations-là et des professionnels
aussi parce que ce qu'on leur demandait
c'est parce que c'est parce qu'on nous
apprend
merci
pour commencer sur la gouvernance des
hôpitaux effectivement je pense qu'il ya
des enseignements à tirer de cette crise
trop souvent je pense que les
informations vont du haut vers le bas du
directoire vers les agents alors que des
instances sont prévues pour que ça
puisse être un échange commun participer
à une réflexion commune avec notamment
le chsct ou le conseil de surveillance
beaucoup trop on voit des instants sous
les ordres du jour sont communs ou les
représentants syndicaux ne peuvent pas
faire remonter à la direction
ce que nous vivons sur le terrain les
problématiques que nous pouvons
rencontrer qui sont vraiment pragmatique
à l'image du conseil de surveillance
c'était un conseil d'administration
avant roues les élus locaux avaient
toute leur place pour permettre aussi
aux la population pouvoir s'exprimer
un conseil de surveillance qui surveille
un hôpital c'est un joli pléonasme
malgré tout puisqu'on peut pas
surveiller un hôpital il faut aussi
l'administré donc toutes ces instances
qui sont réduits mal malgré
malheureusement à des simples du chambre
consultative au juste on lève la main
cet ordre du jour qui sont
systématiquement commun effectivement là
sur cette gouvernance qui était beaucoup
plus agile pendant la crise et parce que
tout le monde je pense y avait une sorte
d'euphorie pour pallier la crise pour
que tout le monde puisse faire de son
mieux avec des semaines à rallonge je
pense pour tout le monde que ce soit de
la part la direction ou des collègues
qui revenaient sur leurs jours de repos
sans arrêt il ya vraiment des leçons à
tirer de cette crise concernant la
balance des hôpitaux en n'ayant point un
point d'ancrage beaucoup plus local de
ce qui se passe dans les gouvernances de
même pellet j'ai acheté il ya des âges
qui ont des étendues pratiquement de 70
kilomètres d'écart avec une seule
direction commune on peut pas gérer un
hôpital à distance surtout avec des
soignants qui ont des heures dérogatoire
comme le 12 heures qui fonde les nuits
des jours qui enchaîne des semaines
éreintantes concernant les masques
effectivement pas les masques ffp2 de ce
que moi j'en retiens des retours qui ont
été faits effectivement c'était pour les
actes invasifs de la sphère orl puis
pour revenir sur les masses de ce que
l'on sait aujourd'hui par rapport au
virus 80% pour 80% du virus qu'il y ait
manuportée c'est à dire c'est par les
jeunes
pour les touchés par les objets et 20%
est reporté on met en avant ce
problématique de masques alors que c'est
d'abord aux gestes barrières qu'il faut
mettre l'accent sur les distanciation
sociale même par rapport aux ehpad ou
autres les ehpad sont un lieu de vie par
effectivement des choix ou des faits ça
a coûté probablement de nombreuses vies
ça a mis un mal être immense auprès des
collègues des équipes des ehpad parce
que les villes incompréhension totale
parce que trop souvent l'amalgamé fait
entre les ehpad qui sont médicalisés et
l'hôpital donc il ya une gestion et un
exercice est un petit peu différent
pardon dans la dans la gestion des ehpad
pour autant effectivement beaucoup d pad
ont dû se débrouiller par eux-mêmes
avant d'attendre des actions
gouvernementales des recommandations et
c'est tout tout la politique interne a
été mis sur l'hôpital sur les
établissements sociaux et ça a trop
tardé pour les ehpad pour nos personnes
âgées et on envoie la catastrophe
puisqu'on a même du mal aujourd'hui
estimé le nombre de pertes à domicile on
a même aucun chiffre et puis bon je
meurs si oui par rapport à la personne
âgée au et aux patients qui ont été
maintenus dans les ehpad le témoignage
de la collègue moi je les ai entendu de
nombreuses fois en effet l'hôpital a été
quasi inaccessible pour les personnes
âgées et ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
est tombé du ciel
la note ministérielle qui recommandait
en effet de maintenir les personnes à
leur domicile ou dans les ehpad les
personnes malades en sachant qu'à ce
moment là il n'y avait alors vraiment
vraiment pas de dépistage
elle date du 31 mars elle date du 31
mars
setek rien c'est écrit dedans voilà on
aboutit à la situation que la moitié au
moins la moitié des personnes qui sont
mortes en france sont des personnes
certes âgé mais moyennement âgées pour
certaines et on peut que se poser la
question c'est comme ça qu'on le formule
nous on se pose la question de pourquoi
est ce que on les a maintenus plutôt que
de leur donner la possibilité d'accéder
à l'hôpital comme n'importe quel patient
répondre à votre question sur la
recommandation sur les parts danse sur
la reconnaissance en maladie
professionnelle
alors là pour l'instant il ya un très
très difficile d'estimer
exactement où on en est de cette
reconnaissance là nous la cgt on a
refait une étude donc courant juin
seulement un tiers de nos syndicats nous
l'indiqué nous ont indiqué avoir
connaissance sur leurs établissements
deux processus de reconnaissance de
maladie professionnelle mise en place
donc à priori les agents ont quand même
la plus grande difficulté à pouvoir
faire reconnaître comme maladie
professionnelle les
leur lait pisé épisodes d'infections
qu'ovide et concernant la reconnaissance
comme accident du travail puisque
quelques démarches de reconnaissance
comme accident du travail
seulement 10% de nos syndicats ont
connaissance de reconnaissance comme
accident du travail effectives
donc là c'est vraiment la grande
question parce que indéniablement vous
citiez les chiffres de santé publique
france tout à l'heure moi je suis pas à
30000 contaminé 1 auquel le dernier
chiffre que j'avais au 14 mai s'était 65
milles 800 personnels de doutes nos
champs autre champ qui étaient
contaminés 14 mai merci je vous laisse
la parole monsieur rapporteur merci
monsieur le vice-président d'abord
permettez-moi d'exprimer ma
reconnaissance personnelle je crois
celle de la commission à l'ensemble des
personnels soignants que vous
représentez et qui ont effectué un
travail vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
vous souhaitiez pas cette reconnaissance
mais je crois qu'il est quand même
important utile et pertinente de la
souligné avec beaucoup de force parce
que l'un d'entre vous tout à l'heure
évalué les points positifs et les points
qu'ils ont été un peu moins dans les
points positifs il ya naturellement le
professionnalisme l'engagement la
détermination de tous les personnels
soignant à l'hôpital public ou dans les
établissements privés dans les ehpad
dans les établissements médico sociaux
dans les services de soins à domicile
donc je veux vous dire notre immense
gratitude parce que si le système a tenu
dans les conditions difficiles que vous
avez rappelé c'est naturellement grâce
grâce à vous je voudrais revenir sur un
point que beaucoup d'entre vous
quasiment la plupart ont soulevé et
cette audition est extrêmement
importante parce que vous exprimer c'est
peut-être la première fois que nous
avons cette audition des personnels qui
ont été au contact direct des
difficultés du terrain au-delà d'une
parole
c'est une parole qui a été entendue ici
mais qui est une parole un peu plus
officielle vous avez une parole
concrètes et je crois qu'elle est
précieuse pour nous parce que
vous avez des propos qui sont un peu
éloignés grands quotidiens de titres et
ce soir que hier on a entendu une
positive attitude
vos propos ça n'éloigne swan éloigne un
peu mais il ya un point qui m'a beaucoup
frappé c'est que vous avez tenus chacune
et chacun une position en disant que des
choix ont été faits dans la prise en
compte des patients c'est une analyse
une position voire une accusation
extrêmement grave qui est contesté au
plan médical où on nous dit que tout le
monde a été accueillie donc sur quoi
vous reposer cette affirmation
vous nous avez indiqué je crois que
c'est monsieur yunus tout à l'heure que
il y avait des choix qui ont été faits
par manque de lits donc est-ce que vous
avez des éléments quantitatifs une
évaluation concrète monsieur souvent
vous nous dites des choix ont été faits
et ça sans doute coûté des vies
donc c'est un point extrêmement
important qu'il faut écrire d'abord à
l'hôpital
et puis henry un service de réanimation
bien sûr comment vous avez vécu c'est
ses choix comment ont-ils été effectuée
est ce que vous en avez été témoin vous
nous avez indiqué madame petit aussi
vous avez évoqué cette instruction
ministérielle cette note si vous l'avez
d'ailleurs on serait demandeur que vous
la transe métier à la commission puisque
il a toujours été dit à la commission
qui avait aucune instruction de cette
nature cette note du 31 mars qui
recommande le maintien année padoue à
domicile ou à domicile
voilà et là aussi avec des conséquences
extrêmement graves
vous avez évoqué madame corbières cet
exemple de saint dizier en eas on les
regarde mourir sans rien faire bon ça
rejoint une expérience qu'en tant qu'élu
local
j'ai connu dans mon département qui pour
l'instant a toujours été contestée par
les autorités de tutelle donc ce point
je crois mérite de votre part vous avez
une expérience
crête une vision concrète de terrain
c'est un point majeur parce que derrière
il ya des vies il ya des vies si on n'a
pas hospitalisés des personnes âgées à
nepad
naturellement on les aphtes très souvent
elles ont été très souvent conduites sur
un chemin qui malheureusement était été
fatale était fatale avec les
conséquences avec une absence de prise
en charge
est-ce que vous avez des éléments
chiffrés est-ce que vous avez des
exemples concrets
et vous comment vous avez vécu
directement ces situations est ce que
vous en avez été témoin directement
je vous remercie oui merci beaucoup
c'est plus mon domaine de compétence que
nous avons là la réanimation quand je
parlais de choix c'était vis-à-vis du
matériel maintenant par rapport au vécu
j'ai plusieurs fois chez intervenu
auprès de différents personne par
rapport à ce qu'on entendait à la radio
ou à la télé il n'y a pas de choix qui a
été fait le ce que l'on vient en
réanimation il ya des critères
réanimatoires qui sont préétablis
ou les tous les patients sont vus j'ai
vu mes collègues médecins faire des
semaines 1 termine à pratiquement trois
à quatre gardes de 24 heures par semaine
pour voir un maximum de patients tous
les services
kovy dans les services de salle de
réveil parce que via votre salle de
réveil qui étaient réquisitionnés pour
faire des chambres de réanimation donc
il n'y a pas de choix qui ont été faits
chez les patients tous les patients et
étudier d'accepter un patient en
réanimation c'est un choix qui lourd et
difficile de conséquences parce que
derrière il ya tout un processus de
réadaptation qui est très lourd très
difficile donc si un patient ne rentre
par animation c'est pas parce qu'on n'a
pas dit c'est parce que derrière il peut
avoir des conséquences très graves pour
lui les conseils c'est difficile de se
relever de ne serait-ce que deux
semaines de réanimation parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de médicaments beaucoup de
manipulations le corps est en souffrance
donc il n'y a pas de choix de à mon sens
c'est dans le terrain tels que j'ai vécu
dans ma structure hospitalière dans le
service de réanimation
il ya aucun moment je n'ai vu un médecin
dira j'ai deux passions
je choisis lequel ça n'est pas non sens
pas arrivé et je pense qu'il y aurait
une levée de boucliers si ça devait
arriver là c'est là où il faut
reconnaître aussi le professionnalisme
que ce soit des paramédicaux ou des
personnels médicaux chacun a pris ses
responsabilités en évaluant le bénéfice
et le risque c'est comme ça qu'on
travaille en médecine et pas de choix
vis-à-vis de l'ue ont été faits quand
j'ai évoqué les choix peut-être que je
me suis mal exprimé
c'était concernant pardon parce que
j'avais noté vous avez indiqué des choix
ont été faits ça a coûté des vies mais
c'est sur le matériel c'est sûr d'accord
voilà oui tout à fait vous mettez vos
micros c'est pas enregistré de cibler
répéter souk avec le micro je suis
désolé donc je disais oui passer par
rapport au choix du confinement des
ehpad effectivement parce que ça a
beaucoup tardé
les ehpad ce sont des lieux de vie qui
sont médicalisés des médecins
coordinateurs qui permettent de gérer
les prises en charges des prix ce qu'on
appelle les prisons soient plus
exactement un des fois ça a tardé et
redescendre d'information mis du temps à
arriver donc les choix tardif de
s'occuper des structures médico sociales
étaient longues là où on a mis l'accent
vraiment sur les structures d'accord
donc ses choix concernés sur
l'hospitalisation des personnes âgées à
nepad c'était plutôt ça votre accord
alors j'aurai pas que j'aurais peut-être
pas là là même la même approche que mon
collègue
moi je pense que des choix ont été faits
et particulièrement sur les ehpad dont
on parle je crois qu'il ya un décret qui
est sorti au delà de la note
ministérielle il ya un décret du 28 mars
décret 2020 360 complétant le décret
2020 293 du 23 mars
2020 prescrivant les mesures générales
nécessaires pour faire face à l'épidémie
de kobe de 19 dans le cadre de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
il est appelé décret rivotril c'est à
dire que dans ce contexte précis de la
crise qu vide on a jugé que des patients
mais essentiellement parce qu'ils
étaient âgés avaient une balance
bénéfice risque effectivement d'une
entrée en animation qui permettait de
dire ou animateurs que il aurait du mal
à les sortir de
de réanimation mais c'est sur des
données statistiques pas sur des données
réelles et pas sur des bases sur des
études des études cliniques
c'est particulièrement vrai mais je
pensais qu'astrid en aurait parlé sur
l'hospitalisation à domicile où on a mis
en place à l'assistance publique dans
cet établissement là-dessus utilisation
à domicile ce qu'ils appellent les gir
les groupes d'intervention rapide
imaginez ce que ça peut vouloir dire
déjà rien que dans le lexique alcan on
n'est pas tellement dans le pit alidor
l'hospitalier là ça il s'agissait donc
devenir intervenir pour les skis les
équipes hospitalières dans les ehpad et
de mettre en place un protocole
préétabli de rivotril notamment sur les
passionne les personnes âgées qui
présentait des dépressions respiratoires
parce qu'on jugeait que de fait si on
les mettait en réanimation et qu'on les
un tube est un protocole de fin de vie
elles le palais le palliatif qu'ovide
mais moi le témoignage que je voudrais
apporter c'est le témoignage de mes
collègues qui ont vécu ça et qui se sont
retrouvés dans les ehpad à mettre en
place ce protocole là sans avoir le
médecin de l'ehpad avec eux et sans
avoir le médecin de l'achat des avec eux
et qui donc sur les dires d'un médecin
des pannes qui avait téléphoné aux
collègues de l'achat des a jugé que ce
patient là était en dépression
respiratoire et qu'il fallait lui mettre
en mettre en oeuvre ce
protocole palliatifs ses revenus la
charge est revenu au personnel non
médical et c'est particulièrement lourd
et on n'est pas formé à ça c'est quelque
chose qui doit être partagée
collectivement dans le doit pas
découvrir les tableaux cliniques
devant le fait accompli quand on
arrivait dans ces établissements c'est
particulièrement dur et ça reste encore
très ancré dans les têtes et les
collègues ont du mal à s'en sortir parce
que quand bien même il s'avèrerait
qu'effectivement il aurait eu des
difficultés sans sortir de la
réanimation
il ya le sentiment de ne pas avoir donné
toutes les chances
excusez moi j'aimerais qu'on
approfondisse pas ce que vous dites est
extrêmement grave
c'est un point qui concerne des milliers
de vies humaines
vous nous dites que dans ces protocoles
aucun médecin n'était intervenu sauf au
téléphone le bond en de façon concrète
dans un ehpad il ya un médecin
coordonnateur qui lui a dû voir le
patient dont qu'il a il a saisi le samu
lolo pitt l'hôpital l'achat des il ya un
refus
enfin refus il ya eu non prises en
charge par l'achat des parts l'hôpital
et la mise en place du protocole comment
chronologiquement tout ça
s'articule-t-il vous dites y'a pas d'
intervention du médecin
vraisemblablement un mot jj travaille
pas en achat d un donc c'est sur des
témoignages qui me sont remontés
le médecin de l'achat des avait
visiblement
visitez le patient avait jugé que son
état était grave que la maladie qu'ovide
avait et développer sa forme grave
il était en détresse respiratoire et il
a appelé le collègue de l'achat des pour
une prise en charge palliative du colis
de 19 sur ce patient là et le collègue
de l'achat des a dépêché une équipe sur
les pattes pour la mise en place du
protocole ce consiste en l'injection par
alain fusent heures de rivotril
notamment oui ce que
10 le collègue est vrai a été mis en
place en catastrophe une organisation
haddock de prise en charge de patients
en soins en fin de vie dans l'émoi dans
l'émoi l'acquis de l'épidémie au regard
du nombre de patients personnes âgées
qui était malade mais selon un circuit
qui était un circuit que jusqu'à
maintenant nous n'avions pas imaginé
c'est à dire que précédemment en achat
décès de l'hospitalisation à domicile ça
suis quand même un circuit
l'hospitalisation quoi qu'il arrive
qu'elle soit à domicile ou qu'elle soit
dans un établissement
il faut quand même qu'un médecin voit un
patient que l'entrée soit préparée que
toutes les prescriptions soient là qu'on
ait un dossier qu'on ait un accord qu'on
est du patient ou de la famille et
cetera et cetera la a été mis des
groupes d'intervention rapide en place
et donc ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'on a
eu des entrées en hospitalisation à
domicile alors déjà selon des protocoles
il a tout à fait raison qu'ils n'étaient
pas les protocoles habituel de soins
palliatifs
d'habitude c'est des pousse seringue
d'habitude c'est des médicaments là
c'était des protocoles période qu'ovide
c'était du matériel covin c'est à dire
les infusions qui sont pas exactement
comme les pousse seringue qu'on peut
pour lesquels les débits sont beaucoup
plus précis et au delà de ça des entrées
parfois la nuit parfois c'est c'était
l'infirmière ou l'aide soignante de
l'ehpad de garde de nuit qui téléphoner
dans certaines épaves et nous on a des
photos dans certaines ehpad y avait sur
la porte coller le numéro de téléphone
de l'achat des directement donc il ya
bien sûr un médecin d'astreinte en achat
d les prescriptions été faite par le
médecin évidemment mais sur le coup
c'était les infirmières qui se déplaçait
directement pour aller voir le patient
et pour démarrer le traitement
enfin le traitement ce n'était pas un
traitement alors on est pas mais tait et
on tente de faire remonter ce qui nous
est remontée du terrain
est ce qu'on est en train de vous dire
en fait c'est ce qui nous est remontée
du terrain
il faudrait des situations précises et
particulière mais on décrit un contexte
général auquel les personnels ont été
confrontés moi je vous engage ray je
vous engage rey a regardé comme il ya eu
deux morts dans les ehpad
je vous engage rey a regardé combien de
malades
combien de résident dans les ehpad sont
décédés du corps vide et combien il y en
a qui ont été transférés à l'hôpital et
à mettre un comparatif avec les
personnes qui ne sont pas dans les ehpad
qui ont été atténuées au vide et qui ont
été pris en charge à l'hôpital et je
pense que cette indication serait
particulièrement intéressante de
comparer la situation et ont des récits
c'est une situation normale
quinze mille décès dans les ehpad s'il
ya une très faible proportion qui ont
transité par l'hôpital
alors on pourrait imaginer le cas
échéant que des choix était fait il me
revient l'honneur de conclure cette
audition extrêmement riche je veux vous
en remercier chacune et chacun parce que
vous nous avez apporté des éléments
extrêmement importants et qui vont très
précisément orienter les conclusions de
notre commission en tout cas de mon
rapport
parce que ce que vous avez dit est
extrêmement important
vous nous avez livré le constat de
l'hôpital qui a tenu mais qui a tenu
avec des restrictions très importantes
le fait qu'une partie des patients
notamment venant des ehpad n'a dans les
conditions que vous avez évoqué pas pu
n'ont pas pu tous y accéder il le fait
aussi et je voudrais peut-être pour
conclure vous interrogez là dessus sur
l'état des lieux actuel que beaucoup de
prise en charge de pathologies orco
vides n'ont pas été effectués dans la
période de crise on était décalés et
donc qu'il y a eu aussi pour certains
patients peut-être une perte de chance
face à face à la maladie donc je
voudrais connaître comment l'hôpital
remonte en charge sur la prise en charge
des pathologies classique et vous
interrogez puisque le directeur général
de la santé vient ce soir de dire en
même temps que notre audition qu'il
fallait se préparer à une seconde vague
si vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
pu tirer les leçons de la crise pour
éventuellement faire face si par malheur
cette deuxième vague se produit donc ça
c'est une question un peu générale sur
l'état des lieux actuel après plusieurs
mois quatre mois de crise maintenant et
puis peut-être je voudrais revenir parce
que je crois que c'est le point
essentiel de vaud beaucoup de points est
essentielle et il y en a pas qui sont
mineures mais ce que vous nous avez dit
sur la prise en charge notamment des
patients dans les ehpad et est
extrêmement important je le redis même
extrêmement grave
vous nous avez décrit un parcours
notamment sur l'hospitalisation sur la
mobilisation des services d'achat des
mets
il ya un lien qui manque qui est
monsieur le président le connais bien il
a évoqué c'est que j'aimerais que vous
m'éclairer de façon très concrète c'est
quand un médecin coordonnateur mesure
par rapport aux symptômes qu'un pass
personnes résidant dans un ehpad et
potentiellement touchées par locaux
vides
il appelle les services du 15 la
régulation et c'est là qu'est ce qui se
passe quand quelle est la réponse qui
est fait pour motiver non prise en
charge
il ya des patients qui ont été prises en
charge venant des ehpad d'ailleurs
beaucoup sont décédées à l'hôpital
venant des ehpad puisque dans les décès
on a vingt mille décès à l'hôpital 10500
en ehpad
enfin peu moins de 20000 à l'hôpital
mais dans les vingt mille décès à
l'hôpital
une partie non négligeable thierry
incarne vient dé est pas donc il ya une
prise en charge de ces patients
pourquoi les autres n'ont ils pas été
pris en charge
comment parce que comme c'est l'achat
des cds jacky a pas la prise en charge
il n'ya pas l'hospitalisation voilà
classique anne hôpital un établissement
et donc on passe dans la structure achat
d et qui se termine par la mobilisation
des équipes d'intervention et les soins
palliatifs donc c'est ce que sur ceux
cette chaîne je crois que c'est
important
ce maillon entre l'appel du médecin
coordonnateur pour dire voilà on a une
suspicion de gros vide
et qu'est ce qui est fait là est ce
qu'il ya eu un changement entre le début
et la
l'apparition de la crise jusqu'au 2
avril on n'a pas de statistiques de
décès dans les ehpad
donc quand on a ces statistiques et un
choc on s'aperçoit qu'il ya plusieurs
milliers de décès est-ce que là il ya un
changement dans la prise en charge est
ce qu'au début vous avez eu le sentiment
que c'était pas une urgence que ce
n'était pas une priorité ou que naïve et
hiérarchisé dans une situation de
tension extrême des priorités est ce
qu'il ya un changement de comportement
dans la prise en charge notamment
lorsqu'on a connaissance que le
l'opinion publique a connaissance de ces
chiffres qui donnent coups font monter
de plusieurs milliers les statistiques
et qui font apparaître devant l'opinion
publique
ce problème qui pour le jusqu alors été
ignorés voire voir quel pouvoir masquer
je vous remercie en tout cas pour la
qualité de ses réponses
vous laissez les gens s'envoient
monsieur le rapporteur alesi un prix non
mais ce sont des questions qui sont
qu'on se pose nous aussi en fait on a je
pense qu'il faut investiguer parce que
de ce que j'ai vu moi
malheureusement face à face à la flambée
de l'épidémie des protocoles non des
procédures on va dire plutôt que des
protocoles n'ont pas toujours été
respectée de la même façon et notamment
pour les entrées en hospitalisation à
domicile même si a priori cesser ce pas
toujours passer par le samu qui
contactent l'achat des il a pu arrivé
plusieurs fois que ce soit un médecin de
l'ehpad voir moi j'ai des témoignages de
soignants mais j'ai pas pu vérifier
qu'ils me disent que c'était parfois des
personnels notamment la nuit qui prenait
contact avec l'achat des directement bon
et comprenons nous bien les témoignages
qui nous sont transmis c'est que ce ne
sont pas des patients qui étaient des
pistes et du co vide qui étaient
signalés et pris en charge par lâcher
des noms malheureusement c'étaient des
patients dans un très mauvais état
physique
voilà les infirmières me décrivait et
c'est traumatisant des personnes âgées
complètement cyanosé depuis trois jours
quand l'achat des intervient voilà donc
ces circonstances là
c'est dans ces circonstances là qu'ils
ont été pris en charge oui pour partie
je dis pas pour tous mais pour partie au
moins on a des témoignages sur les
pathologies non kovy dès la reprise de
l'activité classique fort heureusement
même si elle a été très fortement
impacté pendant la crise elle même on a
continué de prendre des patients en
charge non qu'ovide juste rappeler que
sur le territoire il ya 500 décès par
jour de maladies cardiovasculaires
qu'elle soit infarctus ou avc il ya 500
de morts par jour aussi du cancer là où
on a commencé à s'inquiéter c'est
lorsque les files d'attentes se sont
allongées sur des gestes diagnostic
comme les coloscopies digestive par
exemple
où on a des
des listes encore qui sont très très
longue date entre d'examens
diagnostiques
là on peut juger qu'il ya une perte de
chance
à l'évidence dans ce dans ce schéma là
mais les soignants médecins non médecins
mais de les bouchées doubles aujourd'hui
ils ont donné énormément pendant la
crise
ils ne sont pas au repos aujourd'hui au
contraire ça continue et il ya beaucoup
de discussions dans les services
aujourd'hui de savoir si on va pouvoir
donner les congés annuels à l'ensemble
de
l'ensemble des soignants il ya des
renforts je vous le disais tout à
l'heure qui sont maintenus parce qu'il
ya cette reprise d'activité qui est
importante
alors on s'est posé ces questions là
pendant la crise de savoir qu'est ce
qu'il en était de ses douleurs
thoraciques qui faisait 75% de
l'activité samu et qui miraculeusement
disparaissait autant la traumatologie on
peut l'entendre on fait moins de roller
dans son salon que
que sur que sur les routes mais les
maladies cardiovasculaires les avc
ça doit toujours exister qu'est ce qu'il
en est advenu on sait qu'il ya eu dur de
témoignages de patients aujourd'hui qui
nous disent ne pas avoir voulu venir
dans les établissements quand cet éco
vite parce qu'ils avaient peur de le
choper et de rajouter un tableau
clinique qui était déjà important avec
des facteurs de comorbidité alors est ce
qu'il ya une perte de chance dans ce
contexte là on va pas pouvoir le dire
immédiatement je pense mais il faudra y
être attentif parce que ce sera pas des
dommages collatéraux mais ce sera des
décès ou des complications qu'il faudra
rajouter au bilan au bilan de la crise
elle-même ça c'est une évidence
je déplore enfin j'apprends avec
tristesse l'éventuel deuxième vague qui
arrive parce que je sais pas si on y est
plus près que pour la première et ça
c'est dramatique de voir la situation
dans laquelle on est aujourd'hui
complètement à plat et de devoir
demander dans les semaines dans les mois
qui viennent le même effort voire
peut-être plus fort au même équipe
non renforcé avec la question qui reste
posée de savoir comment cette fois ci il
va se répandre sur sur le territoire est
ce qu'il va nous laisser ses poches
libre de co vide comme la première fois
on n'en sait rien de ça et c'est très
très très très inquiétant
voilà ce que je pouvais vous dire le
flux de patients il est là il est fort
et on essaie d'y pallier malgré tout ce
que l'on a témoigné la ce soit en de
fatigue d'exaspération et de la
sensation de ne pas avoir été entendu
une fois de plus je vais je vais
intervenir sur deux points
alors la prise en charge de la personne
âgée oui effectivement nous pensons que
cela peut être une priorité et que ce
n'est pas aujourd'hui dans notre société
une priorité quand on lit les rapports
les bouts elle comme rio et bien les
difficultés qui aujourd'hui dans les
dents dans les ehpad et c'est un vrai
problème de choix de société aujourd'hui
qui dépasse largement le débat je pense
que nous avons ici voilà qu'est ce qu'on
est prêt aujourd'hui à m pour la prise
en charge de la personne âgée
on voit une montée de l'âgisme en france
suis désolé ça c'est quelque chose que
con qu'on constate régulièrement dans
les ehpad
enfin moi j'ai jamais vu pour réveiller
un médecin coordinateur la nuit à ça se
fait pas ça c'est pas possible ça je
vous le dis à l'autre bout du fil
je peux vous assurer que vous faites
rouler excusez moi du terme
les collègues n'importe quel collecte
pourrait vous le dire c'est une réalité
et les infirmières
je sais pas en ville dans les grands
grands centres mais en milieu rural les
infirmières la nuit il y en a pas il y
en a pas quand il ya des aides
soignantes
on est content donc ça c'est une réalité
donc après est ce qu'on est prêt sur un
deuxième vague
déjà le personnel et va falloir qu'il se
repose
il va falloir qu'ils récupèrent à un
moment et il va pas été chaude et une
deuxième fois avec la déréglementation
ce qu'il a vécu au rythme en attente
mais pas en hasard tu auras pas la
maladie propre fessionnels où il a été
malade mais n'a pas été dépisté donc ont
cette fois ci tu vas pouvoir l'avoir
enfin c'est ça qui nous remonte
aujourd'hui donc je pense que va y avoir
quelque chose là et des signes forts
fort envoyé
parce que aujourd'hui nous on a déjà
nous disent moi je préfère aller
travailler à l usine à côté là je vais
mieux payés j'ai pas les week-ends j'ai
pas le stress
donc c'est tout oublié le reste je
m'estime c'est reviendra peut-être merci
alors pour répondre à la question par
rapport au flux reprise de l'activité je
pense pas qu'il y avait eu une activité
qu'ils se soient stoppés un des points
forts de cette crise et qui a une
couvrait collaboration entre le public
et le privé parce qu' il fallait
collaborer avec le privé dont plusieurs
régions notamment dans le grand est où
le lait de ce secteur privé ou du
secteur non lucratif parce que les au
sictom non lucratif et est très
importante et efficace afin de décharger
les hôpitaux des patients orco vide
parce que j'ai qu'il n'y avait cette
crainte des patients d'aller dans les
structures hospitalières par peur de de
ce qu'on t'aime de contaminer d'attraper
le colis de 19
ensuite pour en venir aux poings de la
deuxième vague
la deuxième vague effectivement et ce
qu'on y est prêt je ne pense pas est ce
que les soignants fourniront le même
effort
bien sûr que oui bien sûr que oui nous
allons retourner dans les services et
faire la même chose si fallu refaire et
on continuerait de le faire le problème
c'est que maintenant est ce que vous
vous êtes prêts à nous aider et nous
donner les moyens et les armes pour
qu'on ait l'énergie et le courage
d'aller encore plus loin
si on devait affronter une deuxième
vague là le ségur c'est maintenant la
deuxième vague c'est demain jeudi
oui je dirai pas plus ou mieux que ce
qui a été dit il ya un manque d'effectif
c'est évident manque de moyens si on
compare y compris avec l'allemagne ce
qui a été fait quoi un nombre de lits de
réanimation par exemple et si on compare
mais si vous comparez la population 65
millions 83 millions si vous comparez le
delta nombre de réanimation on peut
discuter peut-être quand même et donc
les personnels ils sont épuisés il y a
des manques d'effectifs
il n'y a pas de ratio sofa et a par
exemple vous avez des ratios
sauf que area quand vous n'avez pas lily
vous n'avez pas les ratios adopter donc
en vous ouvrir des lits de fortune et de
réa en urgence vous mettez du personnel
qui n'est pas formé à l'art et la voilà
avec tout ce que cela peut comporter
comme aux difficultés donc aujourd'hui
il faut augmenter les effectifs
il faut augmenter des moyens qui sont
donnés à l'hôpital il faut bien
évidemment augmenter les personnels qui
travaillent pour que pour les engager
dans un processus qui a du sens
je me rappelle avoir dire madame du zinc
qui un jour nous disait mais il faut
redonner du sens aux métiers du sens aux
métiers mais quand on soigne les gens
si ça ça pas de sens mais on a perdu on
a perdu l'essence même du sein c'est de
ce que ça peut être les soignants les
professionnels ils ont des valeurs et
quand on les éloigne de leur valeur ce
qui se passe c'est un désengagement une
démotivation on lâche le métier on va
faire deux choses et après vous vous
retrouvez avec 4,5 millions en fermière
qui exercent eux qui font notre métier
comme infirmière donc si on veut
redonner du sens qui à mon avis n'a pas
besoin est redonnons des moyens et les
moyens vous donneront naissance
vous venez à d'écouter les syndicats de
soignants qui ont été très critiques sur
la gestion de la crise et sur l'état de
l'hôpital public défaillance l'hôpital
n'est pas en mesure de faire face car il
n'en a plus les moyens
et puis cette question au coeur des
discussions faute de place à l'hôpital y
at il eu un tri des malades pour
certains représentants syndicaux oui
pour d'autres non cette audition et
toutes celles menées par la commission
denquête sont à revoir tout l'été sur
lcp et sur notre site
lcp point fr